if you could do the patron saint of
something what would it be I'd like to
be the patron saint that goes up to
people praying for things and goes it's
not going to happen
like trust me like I know God it's not
gonna happen I would love to have that
power you're the people but know it for
a fact not for a fact yeah I would love
that you're like the deliverer of bad
news but would you also be the guy who's
like hey no you're gonna get it no no no
only the bad news it's not going to
happen so God God will be like that guy
we're gonna cure his cancer but over
there tell that guy his team's not
winning the Super Bowl it's not gonna
happen just to put in perspective when I
save seats in a movie theater for
somebody when you used to have to do
that I enjoyed saying to people
oh you're a sick like people sliding
down the aisle like coming towarding up
sorry it's taken oh that gives me Glee
that is probably one of people's like
least favorite situations to be in and
you relish it get one more than anything
give it to me you are a sick Pop Joker